fifty-four immigrant children living
reunited with their families today as a
result of a court ruling by a federal
judge that's just over half of the 102
kids under five years old the government
was ordered to reunite by today's
deadline officials said last week that
fewer than 3,000 children in all remain
in US custody the day of Eid al is on
the border in El Paso Texas with the
emotional and complicated reunification
process
Matea good morning well good morning
from the bridge that connects Mexico to
the United States it's one of the
busiest ports of entry in the country we
recently spoke with one my grandfather
who is here in El Paso and hasn't seen
his ten-year-old daughter in nearly a
month they were separated after crossing
the border illegally and he says now
that he knows that she's here in town
he's not leaving until he gets her back
Mario Romero says after his release from
federal custody
he was told he'd be with his daughter in
two days that was two weeks ago do you
believe the government can honestly oh
okay the truth is that I do not believe
them because they say one thing then
they say another Mario says they took my
personal documents and deliver them to
immigration
I don't know what more proof they want
the Justice Department and ACLU go back
to court today to decide what protocols
officials must follow when reuniting
families the government says DNA tests
and fingerprint checks are necessary
under federal law to ensure child safety
but the ACLU says the stricter testing
is inefficient we're working now with 45
fathers and mothers and Taylor levy is a
legal coordinator helping immigrant
families she says her clients have been
asked to send them birth certificates
take fingerprints and pay for a DNA test
they also have to buy the plane ticket
for their child and a roundtrip ticket
for an escort
if the reunions require travel the
system has a lot of good qualities in
terms of protecting against trafficking
making sure that children are who they
say they are that the guardians with
them or whoever's with them in the cross
actually has a right to that child
that's very different than taking a
minor child from their father a mother
Mario Romero says when he finally gets
his daughter back he will not let her
leave his side again what do you want to
do when you were
together with your daughter Madeline
which one Bertha I'm going to give her
lots of kisses he says I'll tell her
that I love her a little and that
everything's going to be okay Customs
and Border Protection is trying to
manage the surge of asylum seekers
they've seen recently over the last two
months eight had over 5,200 family units
come through here of those cases they've
seen only or had only seven separations
by CBP Nora no Maria you've been doing
such great reporting on the border there
thank you so much